I love that tune that coal - it's only a
paper moon cardboard sky that's it and
the poetry is attempting to find out how
much of it is we open how much of it is
this governmental whipped-cream US stock
market on Friday and Monday had one of
its biggest two days sell offs in
history in the wake of all kinds of
financial turmoil in China where more
than 20% of the stock market has lost
its value what the hell is going on here
we're speaking on Tuesday afternoon as
the market is beginning to rebound and
we're here with jim grant of grants
interest rate observer and author of
america's Forgotten depression recent
book world of the 1920s remembered all
of it thank you very much for joining us
it's my pleasure what is your
assessments of what is happening right
now and what will happen in the near
term future well one thing to recall is
that markets are meant to be two-way
propositions they go up sometimes they
go down it has been almost four years
since the stock market pulled back by as
much as 10% which is so what's unusual
is not the churn and chop of an
occasional down day or two or three but
rather the kind of the great sedation
that preceded the down day or two or
three as someone who observes interest
rate yes well nothing actually there
it's very little to observe we don't
have a face anymore
well are we no we missed them are we not
going to now have interest rates for
another seven years what it doesn't
happen what we need that or natural
organic free-range interest rates no
sustainable local interest rates the
kind that grows spontaneously in the
market not the supermarket hothouse kind
the federal government imposes that's
that's what we need now what we will get
is anyone's guess I am guessing that the
Fed has having been loath to to let go
will remain reluctant to let go but that
is sheer guesswork
how much do you see of the last six
years of more or less of a bull market
being the artifact of zero doubt
interests well it's a good question you
know low interest rates flatter
projected future cash flows that is an
arithmetic
fact another fact is that America is is
virtually indestructible there is a
spontaneous sense of enterprise here
that try as they might they really
cannot suppress so some of this is
natural corporate profits have risen
there has been a kind of recovery from
our sorrows of 2008 but superimposed on
all of that has been the the artificial
government convected levitation of asset
values this is the this the plan the
scheme was you to to raise up the prices
of stocks and bonds and real estate that
took the fancy econometric phrase see
but they call it yes the portfolio
balance channel effect otherwise known
as trickle-down so where do you see the
biggest kind of artificial bubbles out
there and what kind of concern do you
have about a 1 1 what what's a good
thing to remember about about finances
that it's it's largely reciprocal there
are assets and liabilities their supply
and demand and the Fed acted to raise up
what they call aggregate demand and so
doing it also lifted aggregate supply
right cheap credit financed cheap oil
cheap copper cheap stuff and we like
that weak American consumers like that
the Fed does not like it so much because
it tends to reduce the measured rate of
inflation the Fed won't you see wants
inflation so the Fed forgot about the
reciprocity of these things it made it
wanted to raise up the demand of the
American consuming public by lifting
stock price ah excellent
lifting up junk bond prices except
behind those prices is real enterprise
real people making real choices about
how to allocate capital and when you get
fake interest rates you get misdirected
flows of investment and enterprise and
effort home of that tune the U net coal
- it's only a paper moon cardboard sky
that's it we are living in to a degree
in a kind
all of our house of Hall of Mirrors I
guess and the poetry is not as knowing
or attempting to find out how much of it
is real how much of it is this
governmental whipped cream I am old
enough to remember the shot a little bit
the Asian crisis of the late 90s when a
lot of bears came out of the woodwork
and said all right this is it you know
our our run is over this is revealing it
and it didn't turn out to be true at
least in the short term for the next
couple of years afterwards what other
any interesting parallels from that
period what's different significantly
well well the one common thread at that
time and this is the is the great
eternal question of what is money and
who says so what is the Chinese renminbi
worth that's the question for today well
it's the currency with the picture of
Mao on the cover it's one of the great
mass murders the 20 that doesn't speak
well the currency doesn't but
substantively what are these pieces of
paper worth that is kind of a persistent
back story
it's a rarely discussed back towards
people confounding Lee to me have come
to be quite accepting of the value
attached by Fiat to these pieces of
paper we call currency we get back again
to markets and prices or prices meant to
be imposed from on high or discovered by
individuals acting spontaneously in
markets well the readers and the viewers
of Reason know the answer to that but
they regrettably are in a minority your
author as aforementioned of America's
forgotten depression of the 1920s what
lessons are applicable from that if any
I'm not sure I won can't dogma ties
about episodes in history and their
applicability today but one thing I did
observe and working on this book is that
severe depression set in after World War
one it kind of came into focus in 1920
and it wreak havoc with employment with
profits with everything you can measure
and and
an economy which word by the way did not
exist but things were very rugged in
America and the government's response to
this was essentially inaction the
Federal Reserve did what many people
would call the wrong thing it actually
raised interest rates the the
administration's of Woodrow Wilson and
warren g harding did not stimulate they
did not do anything except to balance
the budget and lo and behold price is
adjusted wages adjusted importantly and
the twenties proverbial award as some
people say the the past at this point is
a science fiction jim grant thank you
very much for joining some highly
welcome it makes explaining what's going
on the reason TV i am matt lauche